Con este video vamos a entender un poco más,
¿qué es la pendiente de una recta
y su intersección con el eje "y"?
Aquí dice, ajusta la pendiente y la intersección
con el eje "y" hasta que conecte los dos puntos.
¿Cómo afectan la pendiente y la intersección
con el eje "y" a la recta?
La idea principal de estos ejercicios es que
podamos modificar
la ecuación para que la recta que tenemos en esta gráfica pase por los dos puntos que se nos dan.
La ecuación de la recta original que tenemos
aquí es, "1x" más 1,
esta recta es el resultado de esta ecuación, "1x" más 1, tiene una pendiente de 1 y podemos saber eso
porque para cada vez que avanzamos uno a la derecha,
se mueve exactamente uno hacia arriba
y cruza el eje "y" en 1, intersecta al eje
"y" exactamente en el punto 0, 1.
Ok, el objetivo de este ejercicio es cambiar
la pendiente y el punto donde la recta cruza
el eje "y"para que la recta pase por estos
dos puntos que tenemos aquí.
Entonces, ¿qué tenemos que hacer?
Aquí podemos ver que cuando cambiamos la
pendiente, si hago que la pendiente sea mayor,
esto produce una recta más empinada.
Ahora le pendiente es 3, esto significa que
si muevo uno a la derecha,
el punto se mueve 3 hacia arriba.
El cambio en "y" es 3, cada vez que hay un
cambio de 1 en "x".
Ésta es la pendiente.
Pero creo que para conectar estos dos puntos,
no necesitamos cambiar la pendiente en la
ecuación original de esta recta, sino que
lo que tenemos que hacer
es cambiar el punto donde la recta intersecta el eje "y".
La intersección de la recta con el eje "y"
sigue siendo 1, si hago que disminuya el punto
donde la recta intersecta el eje "y", fíjense
que la recta se desliza hacia abajo.
Esto no cambia la inclinación o la pendiente,
solo hace que la recta se mueva hacia abajo
a lo largo del eje "y".
Así que parece que solo necesito cambiar
este punto, para lograr que la recta cruce
por los dos puntos que se nos dan al inicio
de este ejercicio.
De hecho podemos ver que uno de los puntos,
está justo en el eje "y",
entonces vamos a llegar a intersectar la recta
en el eje "y" en el punto 0, -8.
Y llegamos.
La ecuación de la recta que pasa por los
dos puntos que tenemos aquí es "1x" menos 8.
vamos a comprobar la respuesta, ok,
es correcta.
Vamos a hacer otra.
Una vez más, el ejercicio nos presenta la
ecuación de la recta,
"y"es igual a "1x" más 1 pero aquí me da
dos puntos nuevos
y tengo que hacer que la recta pase por ellos.
Y una vez más vemos que se trata de una pendiente
positiva, porque cada vez que me muevo sobre
el eje "x" hacia la derecha, o sea de forma
positiva, el eje "y"se va para arriba,
así que voy a aumentar la pendiente un poco, la
aumento un poco más, se ve bien,
así que voy a mover la recta un poco hacia abajo,
disminuyendo el punto donde la recta cruzael eje "y".
Ahora tal vez pueda cruzar por esos dos puntos.
¡Llegamos!
Esta es la ecuación de la recta que pasa
por los dos puntos que tenemos aquí, 0, -2 y 2, 6.
Tenemos entonces la pendiente igual a 4, que
significa que por cada uno que avanzamos a la derecha,
vamos 4 hacia arriba, lo vemos aquí,
uno a la derecha y 1, 2, 3, 4 hacia arriba.
Y el punto donde la recta
cruza el eje "y" es 0, -2.
Esta es la ecuación de nuestra recta.
Comprobamos, ok.
Vamos a hacer otra.
Una vez más el ejercicio nos da una recta "y" igual a "1x" más 1 y dos nuevos puntos para cruzarlos.
Solo que aquí podemos ver que la pendiente
de la recta que necesitamos para cruzar estos
puntos debe de ser negativa y vamos a modificar
la pendiente de la recta.
Vemos que nos pone fracciones, así que los
saltos serán más pequeños...
así se ve bien...
parece que llegamos a la pendiente correcta.
Ahora vemos que nuestra pendiente es negativa
porque cada vez que avanzamos 1 a la derecha en el eje "x", el punto se va para abajo en el eje "y".
Ahora tenemos que modificar la intersección
de nuestra recta con el eje "y",
también nos pone fracciones, así que los saltos serán
más pequeños, pero estamos llegando.
Y parece que tenemos que ajustar nuestra pendiente...
Ok, llegamos.
Estos ejercicios son divertidos porque es
difícil poner respuestas incorrectas,
podemos estar modificando la ecuación hasta que logremos que la recta pase por los dos puntos que
nos ponen aquí, pero la idea es que podamos desarrollar
la intuición para calcular la pendiente,
que podamos saber cual es la inclinación
de la recta y cual es el punto de intersección
de la recta con el eje "y", si es más abajo o más arriba
y la podemos mover para obtener la ecuación correcta.
Vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta, es correcta.